This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的朋友以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranciini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，这个特定的测试你伪造了两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男。人，格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰奇尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Hello, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the very unprofessional podcast, whereby I, your unqualified guide, talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s. what they mean for our psychology. Welcome back to the podcast. I hope your week has been well,
大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个非常不专业的播客，我作为你们不合格的向导，和大家聊聊我们二十多岁时的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。欢迎回到这个播客。希望你们这一周过得不错，
that something amazing has happened, or you got some, you know, cool news. I'm recording this with a little cat on my lap right now, and it's very, very satisfying. But this week, we're going to be delving into the chaos, the absolute fucking nightmare of the nine to five job. This is a topic that my friends and I talk about all the time, and the general conclusion we most often reach
发生了一些神奇的事情，或者你听到了一些（你知道的）酷炫的消息。我现在正录制着这个节目，腿上趴着一只小猫，这感觉非常非常满足。但本周，我们将深入探讨混乱，绝对他妈的朝九晚五工作的噩梦。这是我和朋友们经常谈论的话题，我们最常得出的总体结论
is that the nine to five jobs should be a body, left for dead. It's not a happy way of life for many, I think, and myself included. So today we're going to talk about how a 9 to 5 is not conducive to a healthy, rounded and happy way of living, especially when we're young. And we're going to have a special guest come on later. But first, let's just talk about some of the psychological concepts behind why a 9 to 5 work week is actually just really terrible. So our work can be a big part of our identity and offer some pretty key insights into what's important to us. So it is a really rich area of psychological study and for many people in their 20s the transition to full-time work is
是，朝九晚五的工作应该被当作一具被遗弃的尸体。我认为，对于许多人来说，包括我自己，这不是一种快乐的生活方式。所以今天我们要讨论的是，为什么朝九晚五不利于健康、全面和快乐的生活方式，尤其是当我们还年轻的时候。稍后我们还会请来一位特邀嘉宾。但首先，让我们先讨论一些心理学概念，探讨为什么朝九晚五的工作周实际上真的很糟糕。因此，我们的工作可以是我们身份的重要组成部分，并为了解什么对我们重要提供一些相当关键的见解。所以这是一个非常丰富的心理学研究领域，对于许多二十多岁的人来说，向全职工作的过渡
very much like the transition to adulthood. We have those fun years and university in high school or we have a lot of freedom to work the jobs and the hours we want and for many that means that we have our days and well our lives just free to do what we wish with. But that can really come crashing down when we enter the workforce and suddenly we have to adapt our lifestyle to the typical nine to five work week. So I've had this experience recently. I work the typical nine to five every day, every week. And after the first few weeks, the novelty kind of wears off. And it really started to wear me down and it can be pretty, you know, fucking depressing. The thing that really got me was that monotonous procedure of going to the same place every day,
非常类似于向成年期的过渡。我们度过了那些有趣的大学和高中时光，或者我们有很大的自由去从事我们想要的工作和时间，对许多人来说，这意味着我们的日子，或者说我们的生活，可以自由地去做我们希望做的事情。但当我们进入职场，突然不得不调整生活方式以适应典型的朝九晚五工作周时，这种自由可能会彻底破灭。所以我有过这种经历。我每天、每周都做着典型的朝九晚五工作。在头几周过后，这种新鲜感有点消磨殆尽了。它真的开始让我感到疲惫，而且可能相当（你知道的）他妈的令人沮丧。真正让我抓狂的是去同一个地方的单调程序，每天如此，
the same commute, doing the same silly little tasks surrounded by the same people. And so much of your day becomes devoted to this bigger entity and what's in the interest of this company or organization, which can be, you know, insanely unfulfilling in many instances. I especially began to notice this when winter struck. You wake up at 7.30, the sun's still down, commute to work, maybe blasting some music so you don't feel like, you know, an absolute robot. And you finish up after five when the sun is set. And where has your day gone? Where is this natural instinct to be active in the sun and outdoors going? With the hours you have left, how do you create fulfillment and an identity in so many short hours in such a short period of time when the sun is down
同样的通勤，在同样的人群包围下做着同样愚蠢的小任务。你的一天中有很大一部分时间奉献给了这个更大的实体，以及这家公司或组织的利益，在许多情况下，这（你知道的）可能毫无成就感。当冬天来临时，我尤其开始注意到这一点。你早上7点30分醒来，太阳还没出来，通勤去上班，可能会放点音乐，免得觉得自己像个（你知道的）绝对的机器人。你五点过后太阳落山时下班。你的一天去哪了？在阳光下和户外活动的这种天性去哪了？利用剩下的时间，当太阳落山且你精疲力竭时，如何在这么短的时间内创造出满足感和自我认同？
and you're exhausted. And I've just come to the conclusion it's almost impossible to remain human in the system and to maintain a concept of yourself beyond your function as a worker or as an employee. You know, you just end up having so little time to be yourself and to pursue things that truly do bring you joy. Now, I know this is not the case for anyone. Some people find work and jobs that inspire them in light of fire under their soul and push them towards really, really great things.
我已经得出结论，在这个系统中保持作为人的状态，并在作为工人或员工的功能之外保持对自我的认知几乎是不可能的。你知道的，你最终留给自己的时间少之又少，无法做自己，也无法去追求那些真正能给你带来快乐的事情。现在，我知道并非所有人都是如此。有些人找到了能激励他们的工作，点燃他们灵魂的火焰，并推动他们走向非常非常伟大的事情。
And some people find it immensely enjoyable and fulfilling to be devoted to people and projects that are bigger than themselves in a sense of purposefulness and productivity. There's also that element of money, you know, in a world where we have to pay to exist, no wonder we've become so conditioned to a system that asks us to sacrifice, you know, the majority of our daily hours to work
有些人发现，全身心投入到比自己更宏大的事业和项目中，并带有一种目标感和高效性，是极其愉快和充实的。这里还有金钱的因素，你知道的，在一个我们必须花钱才能生存的世界里，难怪我们已经习惯了这样一个系统，它要求我们牺牲（你知道的）大部分日常时间去工作，
in an office of something we don't particularly love, just to afford, you know, the small pleasures in life, like rent. Like I mentioned, this dilemma between being a free spirit and embracing our youth or sacrificing these young years for full, time employment is one, I'm sure many of my listeners have experience, especially if you are going through that transition right now. It might even be keeping you up at night, I don't know, but even if you don't have this experience, I think we can or recognize this intense societal
在办公室里做一件我们并不是特别热爱的事情，仅仅为了负担（你知道的）生活中的小确幸，比如房租。就像我提到的，这种在自由精神、拥抱青春与为全职工作牺牲年轻岁月之间的两难境地，我相信我的许多听众都经历过，尤其是如果你正经历着那种转变的话。它甚至可能让你夜不能寐，我不知道，但即使你没有这种经历，我想我们也能（或者说）认识到这种来自社会的巨大
pressure to enter into this system in the corporate world and work our lives and days away until we're 65, retired, no longer have the bones or the stamina for the life that we actually wanted for ourselves. And when I started investigating this and the psychology behind the nine to five job in our 20s, it started feeling even more startling and a pretty shitty deal that we've entered voluntarily into. And I have had this feeling recently. Like at what point did I actually choose this life for myself and come to the conclusion it would bring me happiness? Like how much of that pressure was external or intangible, me feeling this idealized equation for a perfect life whereby, you know, you have a good job. That's the foundation and everything else kind of falls around it.
压力，迫使我们进入这个系统和企业世界，把我们的生活和日子消磨掉，直到65岁退休，那时我们已经没有了骨气和体力去过我们真正想要的生活。当我开始调查这一点以及我们二十多岁时朝九晚五工作背后的心理学时，我开始感到更加震惊，这真是一笔我们自愿参与的糟糕交易。我最近也有这种感觉。就像我究竟是在哪个时间点为自己选择了这种生活，并得出结论它会给我带来快乐的？比如，其中有多少压力是外部的或无形的，让我感觉到完美生活的理想化公式，即（你知道的）你有一份好工作。那是基础，其他一切都围绕着它。
But enough of my rant. Let's just get into the same. psychology behind full-time work. We're going to talk about why a nine to five job is not ideal for making a living, burnout, exhaustion, and the struggle for fulfillment in a modern-day capitalist society. So before we understand the psychological effects of the five-day work week, we have to understand its history. So the truth is, this type of work schedule hasn't always been the standard in Australia or many places in the world. So basically in the 1900s, factory workers, they were known for being forced to work 100 hour weeks or more. But fortunately, after years of activist work and many people fighting the powers that be changed began. And now the 9 to 5
但我的长篇大论就到这里。让我们直接切入全职工作背后的心理学。我们将讨论为什么朝九晚五的工作不是谋生的理想方式、倦怠、精疲力竭，以及在现代资本主义社会中对成就感的挣扎。所以在理解五天工作周的心理影响之前，我们必须了解它的历史。所以事实是，这种工作日程在澳大利亚或世界上许多地方并不一直是标准。所以在20世纪，工厂工人是以被迫工作100小时甚至更长时间而闻名的。但幸运的是，经过多年的维权活动和许多人与当权者的斗争，改变开始了。现在，朝九晚五的
work week has kind of become a standard. And we've certainly been really lucky to have people from the past who've fought for these labour rights and for more free time. However, I think many of us still believe we're not really getting the best deal. So there was a study recently. It was a worldwide study, they had over 3,000 individuals all working those classic eight hours, sometimes more work days. And finding showed that half of these individuals believe they can do their jobs using only five-hour days. This means they think they'd be more productive if they worked fewer hours instead of more, or a four-day work week instead of five, which really kind of poses the argument that working eight-hour days and 40-hour weeks aren't necessarily even effective. And further studies have also shown that
工作周已经有点成为标准了。我们当然很幸运，能有过去的人为这些劳动权利和更多的空闲时间进行斗争。然而，我认为我们中的许多人仍然认为我们并没有得到最好的交易。所以最近有一项研究。这是一项全球研究，拥有3000多名个人，他们都做着经典的八小时（有时更多）工作日。研究结果显示，其中一半人认为他们只需要五小时的工作日就能完成工作。这意味着他们认为如果减少工作时间而不是增加工作时间，或者实行四天工作周而不是五天，他们的效率会更高，这实际上提出了这样一个论点：每天工作八小时、每周工作40小时甚至不一定是高效的。进一步的研究还表明，
those who work a nine to five job versus those who have flexible work hours, more days off and greater emphasis on ledger, they're more likely to express symptoms of depression, anxiety. They're more likely to laugh less, express less satisfaction with how they use their remaining time, and have fewer fulfilling relationships. According to this recent study that I read about, I think it's only around 30% of the US workforce is engaged in their work. So in other words, they're passionate about their work and they feel strongly committed to their companies. But that leaves 70% of workers who are either not engaged or actively disengaged. So that's 70% of the population who have this work lifestyle who appear quite frankly quite miserable
那些做朝九晚五工作的人与那些拥有弹性工作时间、更多休息日和更强调闲暇的人相比，更有可能表现出抑郁、焦虑的症状。他们更有可能笑得更少，对如何利用剩余时间的满意度更低，并且拥有较少充实的人际关系。根据我读到的这项最新研究，我认为美国劳动力中只有大约30%的人全心投入到他们的工作中。换句话说，他们对工作充满热情，并对公司有着强烈的承诺感。但这留下了70%的员工，他们要么没有投入，要么处于消极怠工状态。所以人口中有70%的人拥有这种工作生活方式，坦率地说，他们显得相当痛苦，并且对他们正在做的事情并不真正投入。
and not really engaged in what they're doing. And on average, we spend at least 35% of our waking hours at work. And if we're not happy in our job, then it tends to have pretty far-reaching impacts on other aspects of our lives. And it affects things, you know, like our relationships, our sleep, physical health, our ability to relax. So what is it about this system that creates such unhappiness from a psychological perspective?
平均而言，我们清醒时间的至少35%是在工作中度过的。如果我们对工作不满意，那么它往往会对我们生活的其他方面产生影响深远的影响。它会影响诸如（你知道的）我们的关系、睡眠、身体健康、放松的能力。那么，从心理学的角度来看，这个系统的什么特点造成了如此多的不快乐呢？
I think it's important just to break it down from an evolutionary perspective to begin. So humans, they didn't evolve to work a nine to five job. We evolved as hunter-gatherers and our innate instincts, our minds, our bodies, they've evolved to suit this context, not that of an office. our central nervous system and many of the structures and features of our bodies, including our circadian rhythm, fight or fight system, sensory systems and cognitive features such as our attention,
我认为首先从进化角度来剖析它很重要。所以人类并不是为了朝九晚五的工作而进化的。我们是作为狩猎采集者进化的，我们天生的本能、我们的思维、我们的身体都进化成了适应这种背景，而不是办公室。我们的中枢神经系统以及我们身体的许多结构和特征，包括我们的昼夜节律、战斗或逃跑系统、感觉系统以及认知特征（如我们的注意力），
they've all adapted as a result of that evolutionary environment. So, for example, one of the primary jobs we used to have in a hunter-gatherer society was obviously hunting. And this involved brief spurts of intense activity followed by large amounts of leisure time. Similarly, for those who rely primarily on, you know, gathering. food. This would have required kind of more time invested, but involved large amounts of physical activity, rest time in between, and it was the lifestyle that brought about specific and instantaneous rewards, such as finding something edible. So both elements of this lifestyle have three important aspects that are no longer kind of present in the modern day work environment. So firstly,
都作为那个进化环境的结果而适应了。例如，我们在狩猎采集社会中从事的主要工作之一显然是狩猎。这包括短暂的剧烈活动，随后是大量的闲暇时间。同样，对于那些主要依赖（你知道的）采集食物的人来说。这需要投入更多的时间，但涉及大量的体力活动、中间的休息时间，这是一种带来具体和即时奖励的生活方式，比如找到可以吃的东西。因此，这种生活方式的两个元素都有三个不再存在于现代工作环境中的重要方面。首先，
they have this specific task-based reward. You've got time outdoors, and you're active, and you've got a greater amount of time for leisure as well. So our bodies and minds, they were formed for these activities. They have evolved for environmental stimulation that is varied and involves active and external input from our surroundings. Our genes, they're still expecting that we chase prey or collect roots and seeds, but human innovation, firstly with the creation of agriculture and manufacturing and industry, it's really moved us away from our natural tendencies and rhythms. And this is why the discomfort and boredom of a nine to five job can be so, profound and unsettling for so many of us because we've forced ourselves into a lifestyle that is
它们有这种特定的基于任务的奖励。你有在户外的时间，你是活跃的，你也有更多的闲暇时间。所以我们的身体和大脑是为了这些活动而塑造的。它们为了多样化的环境刺激而进化，并涉及来自我们周围环境的主动和外部输入。我们的基因仍然期望我们追逐猎物或收集根茎和种子，但人类的创新，首先是农业、制造业和工业的创造，确实使我们远离了我们的自然倾向和节奏。这就是为什么朝九晚五工作的痛苦和无聊对我们许多人来说是如此深刻和令人不安的原因，因为我们把自己逼进了一种生活方式，
fundamentally opposed to what our bodies and minds have evolved to do. What's worse, I think, instead of being outside, people now work in these large buildings. They're awfully tightly packed with people, technology, not much ventilation. And instead of being this tribal creature chasing after your next meal or working alone in small groups, humans have become cells, and pretty unindividualized, in a much larger organism, and it's an organism which has little use for their creativity and their individuality. Basically, our genes haven't had much time to evolve to this lifestyle. So working nine to five on small tasks and projects that rarely have much larger meaning or you feel anyone could replace you, it doesn't really fit the logic that's hardwired into our DNA. Like I kind of
这与我们的身体和大脑进化要做的事情根本相反。更糟糕的是，我认为，人们现在不是在外面工作，而是在这些大楼里工作。里面挤满了人、技术，通风不太好。人类没有像追逐下一顿饭或在小群体中独自工作的部落生物那样，而是成为了更大有机体中的细胞，而且相当缺乏个性，这个有机体对他们的创造力和个性几乎没有什么用处。基本上，我们的基因没有多少时间适应这种生活方式。因此，在很少有更大意义的小任务和项目上朝九晚五地工作，或者你觉得任何人都可以取代你，这并不真正符合融入我们DNA的逻辑。正如我所提到的，
mentioned, we've traded brief spurts of intense focus and activity for long days of continuous monotonous work. We traded skilled, knowledgeable work for this cog-like activity and we exist in concrete boxes with little time outside or in nature or as individuals as well. And it's really interesting because a lot of organisational psychology has shown that employers who are willing to adopt an evolutionary psychology approach to organizing their workplaces, they may drastically improve their workers overall physical and psychological health as well as their general productivity. So what impact does the 9 to 5 have on our mental state and our psychological well-being? So not just being asked to fit into a 9 to 5 lifestyle, but also does the things,
我们用短暂的专注和活动换取了长达一天的持续单调工作。我们用熟练的知识性工作换取了这种齿轮般的活动，我们生活在混凝土箱子里，几乎没有在户外或大自然中，或者作为个体存在的时间。这真的很有趣，因为许多组织心理学表明，愿意在其工作场所组织中采用进化心理学方法的雇主，可能会大大改善其工人的整体身体和心理健康以及他们的整体生产力。那么朝九晚五对我们的精神状态和心理健康有什么影响呢？所以不仅被要求适应朝九晚五的生活方式，而且做的事情，
we know, we're not doing the things that we aren't passionate about and we don't really do things that fulfill us cognitively or creatively. And there are some pretty long-term consequences of that. Firstly, we've got fatigue, burnout, depression, existential dread, just to name, just some fun few. And long hours, they do cause fatigue, both physical and mental. And that fatigue affects not just the last few hours of a workday, but all hours of the next day. So an employee who drags back to work after only a few hours of rest at home isn't going to be very productive in the morning. Then the next long day ties them out even more and this kind of punishing cycle begins. They're not going to be able to fulfill their other obligations in life or properly utilize
你知道的，我们没有做我们热衷的事情，也没有真正做那些在认知或创造上充实我们的事情。这会产生一些相当长期的后果。首先，我们有疲劳、倦怠、抑郁、生存恐惧，这仅仅是列举了一些有趣的少数情况。长时间的工作确实会导致疲劳，包括身体和精神上的。这种疲劳不仅影响工作日的最后几个小时，还影响第二天所有的时间。一个在家里休息了几个小时后拖着沉重的步伐去上班的员工，在早晨是不会有多大生产力的。然后第二个漫长的工作日使他们更加疲惫，这种惩罚性的循环就开始了。如果他们精疲力竭、精神上刺激不足或过度刺激，并且还要应付工作场所的压力和生活本身，他们将无法履行生活中的其他义务或好好利用
their leisure time if they're exhausted, mentally under or overstimulated and dealing with the pressures of the workplace and just life in general. And this is particularly pronounced if it's a big life change kind of shifting into that everyday habit, which it is for those in their 20s who are just entering full-time work. And it's probably why we see so much burnout and dissatisfaction in that age group. So burnout, it can happen pretty fast and is projected into all areas of life. It doesn't really help anyone maintaining a nine to five schedule. It doesn't help the individual or the employee who has a group of tired, exhausted, you know, unfulfilled young professionals aspiring for better things
他们的闲暇时间。如果生活方式发生重大改变，开始转变成那种日常习惯，情况尤其明显，对于刚刚进入全职工作的二十多岁的人来说确实如此。这可能就是为什么我们在那个年龄段看到如此多的倦怠和不满。所以倦怠可以发生得相当快，并投射到生活的各个领域。维持朝九晚五的作息对任何人都没有真正帮助。它既不帮助个人，也不帮助那些渴望更好事物和生活更大乐趣的疲惫、精疲力竭、（你知道的）未得到满足的年轻专业人士的雇主。而且不仅仅是朝九晚五漫长的工作时间和工作生活与私生活的模糊界限。这些在年轻专业人士中很常见。对于员工来说，工作更长的时间可能有（你知道的）暂时可以接受的理由。你期望在更高薪水或内在回报方面获得积极的职业成果，但从长远来看，这在情感上或心理上是不可持续的。
and greater pleasures of life. And it's not just the nine to five long working hours and blurred boundaries between work life and private life. They're pretty common amongst young professionals. And for employees, there may be, you know, temporarily acceptable reasons for working longer days. you expect positive career outcomes in terms of higher salary or intrinsic rewards, but long term this isn't emotionally or psychologically sustainable.
倦怠表现为被忽视的个人护理需求、注意力减退、疏离感、人格解体（我在与凯特的节目中谈过这一点）、空虚感、情绪不稳定和抑郁。从长远来看，你如何从反复发作的倦怠中恢复过来？或者你只是适应并开始疏离，关闭通往生活其他可能导致你的日程安排的领域的门？基本上，我想说的是，通过试图从单调的办公室生活的疲惫中恢复过来，你实际上可能开始牺牲其他元素，例如睡眠、热情项目和社交，以适应这种状态，因为你的一天有太多时间被工作占据了。这只会导致你变得有点像自己的空壳。
Burnout, it can present as neglected personal care needs, dim detention, withdrawal, due personalisation, which I talked about in my episode with Kate, emptiness, emotional instability and depression. And in the long term, how do you recover from repeated cases of burnout? Or do you just adapt and begin to detach and close off doors to other areas of your life that might be contributing to your schedule? Basically, I think what I'm trying to say is by trying to recover from the exhaustion of monotonous office life, you might actually begin sacrificing other elements such as sleep and passion projects and it's socializing to adapt because so much of your day is being taken up by your work. And you really only leads to you becoming a bit of a shell of yourself.
我发现了一句名言，我认为它真正捕捉到了这种思维模式。所以工作时间实际上也是生命时间。我不想把我的生命时间只花在工作上。当我读到这句话时，它有点触动了我，让我有点害怕，因为它确实击中了要害，指出了我们为了一个可能根本不在乎我们、甚至可能不知道我们是谁的更大实体而放弃的东西。对（我想大约是200个，超过200个记录）的元分析，
And I found this quote that I think really captures this pattern of thought. So work time actually is lifetime too. And I don't want to spend my lifetime only at work. And when I read that, it kind of sent me a little bit, made me a bit scared because it really does hit the nail on the head in terms of what we're giving up to work for a larger entity that might not even care about us, might not even know who we are. And a meta-analysis of, I think it's like 200, over 200 records.
所有这些学术论文，拥有超过80,000名参与者，想想看，来自13个国家的近一百万名参与者，表明较长的工作时间与职业健康问题以及较高水平的抑郁和焦虑呈正相关，对于那些报告对项目和角色感到不满的员工来说尤其如此。
of all these academic papers, it had over 800,000 participants, so think about that, close to a million from 13 countries, it demonstrated that longer working hours to have a positive relationship with occupational health problems and higher rates of depression and anxiety, and this is particularly the case for employees who report feeling unfulfilled by their projects and their role.
你超越工作场所享受生活的能力变得与你作为这种资本主义齿轮的地位内在地联系在一起，它剥夺了你的健康，剥夺了你的个性。这就是问题所在。如果朝九晚五导致抑郁、恐惧、疲劳、倦怠，为什么年轻人会感到有心理压力
And your ability to enjoy your life beyond your workplace becomes intrinsically linked to your position is this kind of capitalist cog and it strips you of your health and it strips you of your individuality. So this is the question. If the 9 to 5 causes depression, dread, fatigue, burnout, why do young people feel psychologically pressured
去向它屈服呢？我们有一位嘉宾来稍微解释一下这一点，我将在转眼间欢迎她加入。所以欢迎埃伦。你好。嗨。在这个美好的日子、夜晚，大家过得怎么样？
to submit to it? And we have a guest to explain this a little bit and I'll welcome her in just a second. So welcome, Erin. Hello. Hi. How are we all going this fine? Day, night.
对。午餐时间。傍晚。傍晚，午夜，刺激。下班后的播客。下班后的播客。不，这不是节目的主题。我们没有商量好这个。
Yeah. Lunch time. Evening. Evening, midnight, spicy. Podcast after hours. Podcast after hours. No, that's not the theme of the show. We didn't agree on that.
所以埃伦是我的好朋友。这是我们的朋友一周年纪念日。差不多这个时候。差不多这个时候。绝对是的。是的，我想是的。而且，你知道的，她是这个播客的忠实听众。同时也是一个朝九晚五的专家。
So Erin is a good friend of mine. It's our one-year friend anniversary. Around this time. Around this time. Definitely. Yeah, I think so. And, you know, an avid listener of the podcast. And also a bit of a nine to five expert.
我不知道。我觉得你是我们朋友中第一个真正跳进那种生活方式的人？我想是的。是的。我想还有其他几个人，但我去年8月开始了我的朝九晚五工作。所以那快一年了。
I don't know. I feel like you were the first one of our friends to really. jump into that kind of way of living? I think I was. Yeah. I think there are a couple of other people, but I started my 9-to-5 job in August last year. So that's almost a year.
她当时还在上大学。我当时还在上大学，这是一个可怕的主意。如果有人对你说，去读大学学位，同时又朝九晚五周一到周五上班，不要听他们的，他们不是你的朋友，他们不是你的朋友，以最快的速度向相反方向跑去。你当时在修几门课？顺便说一下，我在吃饼干，嗯，我当时在想，这挺好的，我当时在修两门课，然后我不得不选另外两门课来按时毕业，
And she was still doing uni at the time. And I was still doing uni at the time, which is a terrible idea. If anybody ever says to you, do a university degree and work 9-to-5 Monday to Friday at the same time, don't listen they are not your friend they are not your friend run in the opposite direction as fast as you can how many courses were you doing so i'm ending a cookie by the way um i was doing well this is what i told myself it was fine i was doing two courses at the time and then i had to pick up another two to graduate
天哪，为了符合我的另一份工作，这份工作就不说名字了，它是秘密，秘密，秘密，不，抱歉，伙计们，土豆，猫刚刚站起来离开我们。这是一个非常随意的节目。我当时想，我要请来一位专家，但实际上这是一次伪装的友好聊天。这是一次友好的聊天。但我们在谈论工作。
in time holy shit um to qualify for my other job which will remain nameless um it's secret secret secret no sorry guys the spud, the cat just stood up to leave us. This is a very casual episode. I was like, I'm bringing on an expert, but really it's a let's get friendly in disguise. It's a let's get friendly. But we're talking about work.
而埃伦在评论她照顾的猫。所以你去年8月开始的。是的。现在快到8月了。快有一年了。我讨厌提醒你。我知道你的时间观念是……我的时间观念很短。
And Aaron providing commentary on the cat she's looking after. So you started in August last year. Yes. Now it's almost August. It's almost been a year. I hate to remind you. I know your concept of time is... My concept of time is short.
可能是因为在办公室里。一个工作奴隶。当了一年的工作奴隶。有很多，抱歉，又是叮当声，猫，请把叮当声剪掉。没有人想要这个。所以是的，我坐在办公室大楼的一个房间里，呼吸着别人的空气一年了。这有多可怕？但这是其中一件事，我，我想我们对此讨论了很多，但能够，比如，负担得起你想要的生活，在大学的某个阶段，我会去杂货店，我会真心地
Probably due to being in an office. A work slave. A work slave. for a year. There's a lot of, sorry, the jingling again, the cat, please cut the, please cut the jingles out. But nobody wants it. So yeah, I've sat in a room in an office building, breathing in other people's air for a year. How terrifying is that? But it's one of those things that I, I think we've talked about this a lot, but being able to, like, afford the life. that you want at one stage at uni, I would go into the grocery store and I would really
担心我把钱花在了什么上面，现在我和朋友出去喝酒。我可以请朋友。我可以买。优步。优步。是的，我想我尽量做到一切都在合理范围内，因为我赚的钱不是最多的，但它很好，并且有一定的特权与之相关，我当然不希望理所当然地接受它。但正如我所说，我觉得这很好，因为你有点像，哦，是的，让我们谈谈积极的方面。因为显然这不是现代奴隶制。
stress about what I was spending money on and now I can go out for drinks with friends. I can treat friends. I can buy. Uber's. Uber's. Yeah, and I guess I try to still be, do it all within reason because I'm not earning the largest amount of money, but it is nice and there like is a certain amount of privilege associated with that that I certainly, I don't want to take for granted. But also, as I've said, I feel like it's good because you're kind of being like, oh, yeah, let's talk about the positives. Because obviously it's not modern day slavery.
就像，我们真的很夸张。我知道这个节目的早期部分是我在说，去他妈的朝九晚五。我的生活太难了。就像，我拿到的薪水（你知道的）在前2%为了什么都不做。我不是什么都不做。我认为我其实做了
Like, we really make it. Like, I know a lot of the early part of this show was me being like, fuck the nine to five. My life's so hard. Like, I get paid, you know, in the top 2% to do nothing. I don't do nothing. I think that I actually do kind of. a lot of work but like you know Aaron's made a very good point
很多工作，但就像（你知道的）埃伦提出了一个很好的观点，这是你自愿签署的合同，就像（你知道的）你知道你将要面对什么，你可以负担你喜欢的东西，突然间我所处的位置至少比我以前做的不在乎你的健康和幸福的临时工作要好得多，
this is something you signed a contract voluntarily like you know what you're getting into you get a forward things you like and it's suddenly the position I'm in at least is a lot better than a casual job that I used to work in that doesn't really care about your health and wellbeing
所以我目前的工作环境试图（你知道的）确保他们的员工得到妥善照顾，我们有代表我们权益的人，是的，你知道的，我们有——我是工会成员，我强烈鼓励
so the workplace that I'm in at the moment tries to you know make sure that their workers are looked after properly and we have people advocating for our rights and yeah you know we've got like I'm a member of the union which I strongly encourage
你们所有人，所有的听众，如果你还没有加入工会，一定要加入，因为他们是倡导你工作场所积极改变的人，是的，我认为这是一集非常社会主义的节目，而且我不知道，我也觉得我们谈过，因为我们在录制前吃了晚饭，我们
you all to be all of the listeners if you're not signed up to your union definitely do that because they're the ones advocating for positive change in your workplace yeah this is a very socialist episode I think and I don't know I also think we were talking because we had dinner before this and we were
谈论过，我知道你不能真正深入谈论，因为你不想被你工作的某个听众起诉。我正要说出一个人的名字。你知道我正要说谁的名字。但是的。但我也觉得有时他们并不总是把你的最大利益放在心上。就像你经历过相当糟糕的经历，他们对让你保持灵活性相当冷淡。
talking like I know you can't really get into it because you don't want to get sued to whoever someone from your work listening is. I was about to say someone's name. You know, whose name I was about to say. But yeah. But I also think that sometimes they don't always have your best interest at heart. Like you've had a pretty shitty experience whereby they were pretty standoffish about letting you be flexible.
这确实提出了这些问题：为什么我被强迫进入朝九晚五、五天工作周，既然A，我甚至没有生产力。B，这对我的健康真的很不好。C，你们甚至不需要我在这里。是的。是的。所以我从一个精神疾病患者的角度来看待这个问题。所以我一年前在我的工作中每周工作五天。哦，土豆。
And it really kind of raised those questions of like, why am I being forced into a nine to five, five day work week when A, I'm not even being productive. B, it's really bad for my health. And C, you guys don't even need me here. Yeah. Yeah. So I come from this standpoint as somebody with a mental illness. And so I worked five days in my job a year ago. Oh, Spud.
制造噪音。这很有趣。所以作为一名精神疾病患者，一年前我在上大学时每周工作五天，然后我减少到四天来上大学。我的生活变得无比轻松。目前在我现在的工作中，我正试图做到这一点。我快做到了。这需要大量的谈判和为自己争取权益。但我认为你大概能证明这一点。我已经感觉好多了，因为我认为有一个巨大的概念，每个人一生中都会问你，
Creating noise. It's fun. So as somebody with mental illness, I worked five days in my job a year ago when I was doing uni and then I dropped down to four days to do uni. And my life became eminently. so much easier. And currently in my current job, I'm trying to do that. I'm nearly there. It took a lot of negotiating and a lot of advocating for myself. But I think you can probably attest to this. I already just feel so much better because I think there's a huge concept of everybody always asks you your whole
你要去哪里工作？你要做什么？你长大后想成为什么样的人？他妈的。我讨厌这个问题。每次你看到，我不能说这个，因为他们听这个。但特别是老年人经常会问。这就好像，为什么我需要回答你？我21岁，22岁。就像我不知道。此外，它只是把所有的重点放在了——你要做什么工作？
life, where are you going to work? What are you going to do? What are you going to be when you grow up? Fucking hell. I hate that question. Every time you see, I can't say that because they listen to this. but like especially older people will often ask that. And it's like, why do I need to answer you? I'm 21 years old, 22 years old. Like I don't know. Also, it just puts this whole emphasis on like, what are you going to do for work?
就像工作就是你的整个生活。我记得我告诉某人——我要休息一年，他们就说，哦，哦，你要做什么？我说，我要做一些有创造性的事情。我就想，哦，那对你的简历真的很好。然后——你之后要做什么？我说，嗯，我不知道。就像，让我成为我自己，让我存在着。
Like work is your whole life. And I remember I told someone like, I'm going to take a year off. And they were like, oh, oh, what are you going to do? And I was like, I'm going to do creative things. I'm like, oh, that would be really good for your resume. And like, what are you going to do afterwards? And I was like, well, I don't know. Like, just let me be, just let me exist.
是的。太多的价值被放在了你的生产力和你的职业生涯上。就像，我一直在听很多其他的播客。当然，这个播客，忠实的听众。是的，你什么意思你在听其他他妈的播客？但我听了很多关于财务和职业的播客。我，就像，世界各地有一个美丽美丽的脸书帖子。
Yeah. So much, so much worth is put on to your productivity and what your career is going to be. Like, I've been listening to a lot of other podcasts. Of course, this podcast, loyal listener. Yeah, what do you mean you're listening to other fucking podcast? But I've listened to a lot of podcasts that are talking about finances and careers. I, like, there's a beautiful, beautiful Facebook post out here out there in the world, rather. And it basically says, what's your dream?
它基本上说，你的梦想工作是什么，问号。我根本不梦想劳动。这正是，这正是我的感受。就像我真的，直到我开始每周有三天留给自己，四天留给工作，我才有了平衡。就像，如果你不这样做，我确信有很多人有非常棒的工作能满足他们，这就是他们想做的。但我经常坐在办公桌前想，哦天哪，我愿意付出一切去外面。我盯着窗外说，我为什么在这里？我认为就像，我在工作中学到了很多技能，诸如此类。我认为你越有工作生活平衡，去上班就越不是一件可怕的事情。所以对我来说，比如拥有灵活的工作安排和兼职真的
dream job question mark. I simply do not dream of labor. And that's exactly, that's exactly how I feel. Like I really, until I started having three days on the weekend for myself and four days during the week for work, I had no balance. Like, and if you're not, I'm sure that there's people with really amazing jobs out there that fulfill them and that's what they want to do. But I often sit at my desk and just think, oh my goodness, what I would give to be outside. And I stay out of the window and I go, why am I here? And I think it's like, there's so many skills that I've learned at work and all of that. And I think the more that you have a work life balance, the more going to work is something that isn't terrible. And so for me, like having flexible work arrangements and working part time has
很有帮助。你，但快速问一句，你认为一周有五天你能拥有灵活的工作生活平衡吗？哦，绝对不能。不知道。四天工作周快来吧，说实话。无论是谁想出每周工作五天、周末休息两天的概念，这根本不够做。就像我形容的那样，我有一天带给我快乐。
really helped. Do you, but quick question, do you think you can have a flexible work life balance of five days of your life. Oh, absolutely not. I don't know. Bring on the four-day work week, honestly. Whoever came up with this concept of having to work five days a week, two days on the weekend is simply not enough to do. Like I describe it as I have my day that brings me joy.
我有一天处理生活琐事，然后我有一天做任何我想做的事。是的。所以所有那些像放松、洗衣服的事情。哦，我想那是生活琐事。但你知道我的意思吗？就像那些你必须做的事情——比如维护类的东西。照顾你的植物。
I have my day of life admin and then I have my day to do whatever I want. Yeah. So like all of the stuff that like the relaxation, the laundry. Oh, I guess that's life admin. But you know what I mean? Like the stuff that's like you have to do like maintenance kind of stuff. Look after your plants.
照顾我的植物。我生命中的几个小时都花在了我的植物上。但这是充实的。它是。它是。这是我在乎的事情。我还记得说到你坐在办公桌前说，我只想去外面。
Look after my plants. Hours of my life going to my plants. But it's fulfilling. It is. It is. And it's something I care about. And I also remember speaking of like you being at your desk being like, I just want to go outside.
是的。我记得当你告诉我你在那栋大楼的旧工作时，我吓坏了。是的。你会对我说，哦，今天下着瓢泼大雨。但我向自己保证，一定要在外面吃午饭。所以我去外面坐着。是的，我过去常坐在雨中。
Yeah. I remember being terrified when you told me when you're working at your old job in that building. Yeah. You would say to me like, oh, it was bucking down rain today. But I've made a promise to myself to always eat my lunch out. So I went and sat outside. Yeah, and I used to sit in the rain.
是的，我当时就想，哦天哪。听起来他妈的太糟糕了。就像，你是。是的。我的意思是，我做的另一件事，因为我真的很享受一整天都坐在里面，那就是在外面吃午饭。我尽可能经常这样做。而且我骑自行车上下班。我最近对我的室友说，向内尔大声喊话，如果你在听的话。
Yeah, and I was like, oh my God. Sounds fucking terrible. Like, you are. Yeah. And I mean, the other thing I do, because I really don't enjoy sitting inside all day, is I eat lunch outside. I try to do that as often as I can. And I cycle to them from work. And I was saying recently to my housemate, shout out to Nair, if you're listening.
嗨。是的。嗯，我工作中最喜欢的部分现在不是工作，因为工作永远不会是我一天中最喜欢的部分。但实际上是骑自行车上下班和锻炼，因为这就是我建立照顾自己的方式，当一天中的八个小时——在冬天也就是你所有的日光时间都消失了。简直一无所有。
Hi. Yeah. Um, that my favorite part of work now is not work because work would never be my favorite part of my day. But actually cycling to and from work and doing exercise because that's how I've built in looking after myself when eight hours of the day, which in winter is all of your daylight hours gone. Literally nothing.
我们住在堪培拉，日落时间是五点。日落是五点。所以如果你朝九晚五地工作，你就没有日光时间。这就是我锻炼的动力，因为我骑自行车。我骑自行车上下班，因为我很幸运能这样做，显然这不是每个人都能做到的，但这真的、真的对我有很大帮助，并有助于维持我的心理健康。我认为非常有趣的是，实际上，
We live in Canberra and it's like sunsets at five. Sunsets are five. So if you're working nine to five, you don't get daylight hours. And so that's my motivation to exercise as I cycle. I call to and from work because I can, luckily, which is obviously not something that everybody can do, but that really, really helps me and helps maintain my mental health. And I think the really interesting thing, actually,
朝九晚五和我真正意识到我必须照顾我的心理健康之间可能存在直接关联。就像，我不知道你是否记得我开始工作时，我突然——就像我的朝九晚五工作，我突然非常喜欢跑步，因为我想，我必须这样做。不，和一条大狗散步。我会说，你在做什么？因为我们过去住得
there's probably a direct correlation between 9 to 5 and me actually realizing I have to look after my mental health. Like, I don't know whether you remember that when I started my job, I like suddenly, like my 9 to 5 job, I suddenly got very into like running because I was like, I have to. No walks with a big. I'd be like, what are you doing? Because we used to live around
字面意思相距只有100米。你会说，你在做什么？我能过来吗？你会说，我在散步。是的，只因为我需要呼吸新鲜空气并在外面。这是一件大事。我今天有了这个顿悟
like literally like 100 metres from each other. And be like, what are you doing? Can I come over? You'd be like, I'm on a walk. Yeah, just because I needed to breathe fresh air and be outside. Which is a big thing. And I had this realization today
当我离开公司的时候。顺便说一句，我们，我不知道你怎么样。我爱我的工作。就像，我爱和我一起工作的人。好吧，很不一样。我很高兴你有这种感觉。是的，就像。我爱我工作中的人，但我并不。
when I was leaving work. And just quickly, disclaimer, we, I don't know about you. I love my job. Like, I love the people I work with. Okay, very different. I'm so glad that you feel that way. Yeah, like. I love people at my work, but I don't.
认为我有同感。我上班是为了拿薪水。希望有一天。我也是。就像，如果我是志愿者，我不会去。有些人会去上班，如果他们——如果他们没有得到报酬，因为那是——他们被洗脑了，这就是原因。简单的解释。就像人们，不，不明白。这也是像老年人做志愿者一样。我就想，我懂，但我也想，为什么？我不知道。我就想，你已经过完了你的一生，现在你退休了。你要去免费工作，因为你做不了
think I share the same sentiment. I go to work to get paid. And hopefully one day. Well, me too. Like, I wouldn't go if I was a volunteer. There are people who would go to work if they, if they weren't being paid because that is... They've been brainwashed, that's why. Simple explanation. It was like people, no, don't get it. It's also like people who volunteer, like, in old age. I'm like, I get it, but I'm also like, why? I don't know. I'm like, you've lived your whole life, and now you're retired. You're going to go work for free because you can't do it. anything other than work. I actually really like volunteering though. But if it's like, I don't know, maybe I'm just dissing what I haven't tried yet. Yeah, I think it depends what volunteering you're
除了工作之外的任何事情。不过我其实真的很喜欢做志愿者。但如果像是，我不知道，也许我只是在贬低我还没尝试过的事情。是的，我想这取决于你做什么志愿者。
doing. I find a lot of satisfaction in volunteering because I know that what I'm doing actually contributes. But is it like, but you're outside? Because you often do like tree planting, volunteering, oh, at the food power. Not always, though. I did volunteering for a while where I worked in like a vignies, like an equivalent of vignies overseas. And I loved that. That was amazing. That was a lot because of like human connection as well and being able to talk to people. Okay, you actually didn't think that. Yeah, and I volunteer for a group called C-Change
在做的事。我从志愿者活动中找到了很多满足感，因为我知道我做的事情确实有贡献。但感觉像是在户外吗？因为你经常做类似植树的志愿者活动，哦，在食品救济站。不过也不全是。我有一段时间做志愿者是在类似文创店的地方，就像海外文创店的同类地方。我非常喜欢。那太棒了。很大一部分原因也是因为人与人之间的联系，以及能够和大家交流。好吧，你其实没想到这点。对，我为一个叫 C-Change 的组织做志愿者
who are a non-for-profit in Canberra. And I do that because I like it. And I think I like the feeling of contributing to being part of a community. That's like a big value for me. Yeah. So. Community is another big thing we should talk about. Yeah, definitely.
他们是堪培拉的一个非营利组织。我做这件事是因为我喜欢。而且我想我喜欢那种为融入社区做出贡献的感觉。这对我来说是一个很重要的价值观。对。所以。社区是我们应该谈论的另一个大问题。对，绝对是的。
But yeah, I don't know. And I think that's probably what I do enjoy about work is having like a network of people. Yeah. That's what I was saying about my work. Like I really love the people I work with. Like the things I do feel somewhat meaningful. I have responsibility.
但对，我不知道。我想这可能就是我真正喜欢工作的地方，那就是拥有一个社交网络。对。这就是我刚才说我的工作的原因。我真的很喜欢我的同事。我做的事情多少也有点意义。我有责任感。
And I think that is really important, by the way, not to interrupt you, but if you are working in a 9-to-5 job and you have the ability to change where you are and you are not feeling fulfilled where you are, just move. Find somewhere that does fit. Yeah, if you have that flexibility.
我觉得这真的很重要，顺便说一句，不是为了打断你，但如果你在做一份朝九晚五的工作，而且你有能力改变现状，并且你在当前的地方感觉不到充实，那就跳槽吧。找一个真正适合你的地方。对，如果你有这种灵活性的话。
Well, so what Erin's talking about. Like I am a notorious job quitter. Like if I don't like where I'm working, quit. Quit, quit. Like, as you should. Yeah. Life is too short. I know.
好吧，这就是艾伦在谈论的。比如我是个出了名的爱跳槽的人。如果我不喜欢我工作的地方，辞职。辞职，辞职。就像，本该如此。对。生命太短暂了。我知道。
That's what I used to say. If you have the option to, life is way too short to sit in a job. Yeah. And especially I think while you're young and you don't have a mortgage. You don't have kids. You don't have looming financial responsibilities. Why not? Yeah.
我以前就是这么说的。如果你有这个选择，生命太短暂了，不应该耗在某份工作上。对。尤其是我觉得在你年轻的时候，你没有房贷。你没有孩子。你没有迫在眉睫的财务责任。为什么不呢？对。
And this is the thing about like being in your 20s. Like a lot of us do have that. freedom and it's like why do we submit to something that doesn't work for us and I had that like my friends used to always joke with me like you're a notorious like oh how many jobs are you working now like where are you working now Gemma because I would constantly change but I had this really very strong feeling like right now well does my oyster yeah so much freedom why would I stay in a workplace that I don't feel valued in working hours I don't feel valued in you know it just isn't
这就是二十多岁时的状态。我们很多人确实拥有这种自由，这就好像为什么我们要向不适合我们的事情妥协。我以前也有过这种感觉，我的朋友们总是跟我开玩笑说，你真是一个出了名的……哦，你现在在做几份工作？你现在在哪里工作，杰玛？因为我经常换工作。但我当时有一种非常强烈的感触，那就是当下世界任我驰骋，对吧？有这么多的自由，为什么我要留在一个让我感觉不到自我价值、工作时间让我感觉不到自我价值、你知道的，根本不
worth it and it's not worth it when you're young and you have so much health and stamina and opportunity and friendships. Yeah. To just sacrifice that. Yeah. And this is like obviously there are people in positions to not, yeah, who can't do that. Yeah.
值得的工作场所呢？当你还年轻，拥有如此健康的体魄、精力、机遇和友谊时，这样做是不值得的。去牺牲这些。对。显然有些人身不由己，无法做到这一点。对。
And in which case I think I had an amazing conversation with my psychologist the other day about the concept that if you do have to be where you are and like that's something that's important to you because you need to grow your income or for whatever reason, you know, you. Maybe you do have financial responsibilities. Yeah, yeah. And in some ways as well, there are people who work to support what they love in other aspects of their life. So they'll work to be able to do other things that they really like.
在这种情况下，我觉得前几天我和心理医生有了一次非常棒的对话，谈到了这样一个概念：如果你不得不留在原地，而这又对你很重要，因为你需要增加收入或者出于其他任何原因，你知道的，也许你确实有财务责任。对，对。从某种意义上说，也有人为了支撑他们生活中其他热爱的事物而工作。所以他们工作是为了能够做其他他们真正喜欢的事情。
And I think that's, you know, that's obviously of value as well if you do have that kind of balance. But my psychologist, I'm not going to name her, but shout out. Love her. To you. Shout out to you. Tell her to listen to this. I will. I will tell it.
我认为这，你知道的，如果你有那种平衡的话，显然也是有价值的。但我的心理医生——我不打算说出她的名字，但要大声感谢她。我爱她。向你致敬。向你致敬。让她听听这个。我会的。我会告诉她的。
I think she'd like it. Get a little bit of a patient. So we can get some more the listeners. Many people in Canberra are public servants. I would say the majority of our friends, I would say almost all of our friends, work in jobs that either serve the public service or are the public service.
我觉得她会喜欢的。找一个小病人。这样我们就能吸引更多听众。堪培拉的许多人都是公务员。我想说，我们的朋友中大多数人，可以说几乎所有的朋友，从事的工作要么是为公务服务，要么就是公务员。
So even if they are not working in a department or like a branch or a group, like that's what my job is primarily serving the public service. So you really like, it gets ingrained in you. And there's a lot of actually there are benefits. Like there's a lot of flexibility. in the public service and I'm able to go down to four days a week at the moment because of the flexibility with that. But anyway, so she was talking about this concept of happiness, if you are not somebody who loves to work and work as your life,
所以即使他们没有在某个部门、分部或小组工作——比如我的工作主要就是为公务服务。所以你真的会把这种观念根深蒂固在心中。实际上这也有很多好处。比如公务服务有很多灵活性，由于这种灵活性，我现在可以一周只工作四天。不管怎样，她当时在谈论这样一种幸福的概念：如果你不是那种热爱工作、把工作当成生活全部的人，
happiness is not just going to strike you at work like a lightning bolt from above and you're not just going to sit there and become super deliriously happy. Yeah. It's not going to happen. And for all my life, I think, because of the conversations that everybody has around careers and work and, and what you're going to be and finding fulfillment through what you do. I always thought that if I found a job that fit totally right, I would just experience insurmountable happiness. Like a dream job.
幸福是不会像天上的闪电一样突然降临到你的工作中的，你也不会只是坐在那里就变得欣喜若狂。对。这是不会发生的。而且我一辈子都认为，由于每个人都在谈论职业、工作、你要成为什么样的人以及通过所做的事找到成就感，我总是认为如果我找到一份完全合适的工作，我就会体验到无法逾越的幸福。就像一份梦想中的工作。
Like a dream job. Oh my goodness. The concept of a dream job. Consent of a dream job. Abolish it. Reh. Concept of a dream job. Hate it.
就像一份梦想中的工作。哦，天哪。梦想工作的概念。梦想工作的概念。废除它。呸。梦想工作的概念。讨厌它。
Because she literally said, even if you work in something that you're completely fulfilled in, it is scientifically impossible to be happy eight hours of that day. Yeah, true. You can't. Yeah. Or to be stimulated. Or to be stimulated.
因为她直截了当地说，即使你从事着一份让你完全感到充实的工作，要在这一天里的八个小时都感到幸福，从科学角度来说也是不可能的。对，没错。你做不到。对。或者说要全程保持兴奋。或者说要全程保持兴奋。
Or not bored. Or not bored. Constantly. And even if you are stimulated, you're probably stressed. Yeah. You can't keep your attention for eight hours of a day. It's literally scientifically impossible unless you're on drugs. Yeah.
或者不感到无聊。或者不感到无聊。时刻保持这样。即使你感到兴奋，你可能也是处于压力之中。对。你无法在一天的八个小时里都保持注意力集中。这在科学上简直是不可能的，除非你磕了药。对。
Even then, you still need to go to the bathroom. Maybe not. I don't know what you're taking, but. And for me, that just, I found it such a concept. And she said, you've got to create moments of happiness in your day at work. So for me, I like cycle to them from work. That's a huge bit of my. happiness I have lunch with my friend shout out Lindsay love you friend of the show friend of the show
即便如此，你还是得去上厕所。也许不用吧。我不知道你在吃什么，但是……对我来说，我觉得这真的是个概念。她说，你必须在工作日里创造出幸福的时刻。对我和我来说，我喜欢骑自行车上下班。这是我幸福感的一个重要来源。我和我的朋友吃午饭——大声感谢林赛，我爱你的朋友，本节目的朋友，本节目的朋友。
um I have lunch with her almost every day I love it half an hour to just chat shit yeah about the world yeah um not the public service though we never chat shit about the public service never totally numb we would never talk about work on our lunch break no abolish work yeah actually you shouldn't talk about you shouldn't we had sorry just to interject we had this moment no it's like we were having dinner just like hanging out and we got into like work chat And I like came and we haven't seen each other for like a week. Gusting. I was sitting on the couch and I got into work chat.
嗯，我几乎每天都和她一起吃午饭。我太喜欢了。有半个小时可以随便瞎聊。对，聊聊世界。嗯，不过不是聊公务员的事，我们从不聊公务员的废话，绝对不聊。我们才不会在午休时间谈论工作呢。不，废除工作。对，其实你不应该谈论，你不应该——我们有——抱歉，插话一下，我们当时有这样一个时刻——不，就像我们一起吃晚饭，只是闲晃，然后我们就聊到了工作。然后我走过去，我们已经有一个星期没见面了。真糟心。我坐在沙发上，然后聊到了工作。
Oh. And I really had a moment where I was like, I always promised myself. Did you ever do this when you were a kid? You're like, I'm not going to work a nine to five. Like people who talk about work on their free days, they're so lame. And then there I was. I have never ever pictured myself sitting in front of a computer in an office. And I've been doing that for a year of my life.
哦。我真的有那么一瞬间觉得，我总是向自己保证。你小时候做过这种事吗？你会想：“我才不要做朝九晚五的工作呢。那些在休息日还谈论工作的人真是太逊了。”然后我就成了那样的人。我从来没有想象过自己会坐在办公室的电脑前。而我这一年的人生都在做这件事。
Wow. And I have many moments during the day where I sit there at my computer and I go, what the heck is going on here. What am I doing? Crazy. What am I doing? But, you know, it's skills gaining. It's the way of the world.
哇。我在白天有很多时候坐在电脑前，心里就在想，这到底是怎么回事。我在干什么？太疯狂了。我在干什么？但是，你知道的，这在积累技能。这就是现实世界的生存法则。
It's the way of the world. It's one of those things. And I don't think anybody preps you for it. No. Well, I actually think maybe they do. Like school kind of preps you for it. Think about like going to school. But that's the thing.
这就是生存法则。事情就是这样。而且我觉得没有人会为你提前做好心理准备。没有。好吧，其实我觉得也许他们会。比如学校某种程度上会为你做准备。想想去上学。但问题就在这里。
I had this thought and not in a good way that it preps you for it. But like a whole life we're conditioned to give up the hours of our day. to something that we might not always see a purpose in. Like, you go to school from 830, 3.30, and then, you know, you go to work from 9 to 5. Like, I used to fall asleep in school classes. Yeah, I'm sure you would have. You would have been so bored. How can you sit down that long?
我有过这种想法，并不是什么好想法，觉得它是在为此做准备。但就像整个人生中，我们都被训练成习惯于把一天中的几个小时交出去，交给我们可能并不总能看到意义的事情。比如，你从八点半到三点半上学，然后，你知道的，你从九点到五点上班。比如，我以前在学校上课时会睡着。对，我敢肯定你确实会。你一定无聊透顶了。你怎么能坐那么久？
Anyway, so in terms of creating happiness in your workday, so you don't feel like that, like me sitting at my desk going, what the fuck am I doing? Having an existential crisis every single moment, you know. She was like, go get coffee if that's something that you like. Do something in the builds, connect. if that's something you like, you know? And I really, I really appreciate that concept and like going for a little walk in the afternoon.
不管怎样，所以在如何让你的工作日变得快乐方面，这样你就不会有那种感觉，就像我坐在桌前想着，我到底在干什么？每时每刻都在经历存在主义危机，你知道的。她说，如果你喜欢的话，就去买杯咖啡。做点能建立联系的事，如果你喜欢的话，你知道吗？我真的很，真的很赞赏这个概念，比如下午去散一会儿步。
Do you do it. Go for a little walk. Who's stopping you, you know? And let's talk about that. So that's actually really good skills, like really good habits to form. Because I feel like I don't have that right now. Like, I often skip my lunch break. I often don't go outside.
你做这件事吗？去散一小会儿步。谁在阻止你呢，你知道吗？我们来谈谈这个。这其实是非常好的技能，也就是培养非常好的习惯。因为我觉得我现在没有这种习惯。比如，我经常跳过午休。我经常不出门。
Absolutely not. I drive to work. And then today I saw the sunset and I like almost cried because I was like, wow. real existence. But let's talk about making the most of your off time because you do a really good job at that. Do I? Yeah, you do it.
绝对没有。我开车上班。然后今天我看到了日落，我差点哭出来，因为我觉得，哇，这才是真实的存在。不过我们来谈谈如何充分利用你的业余时间吧，因为你在这方面做得真的很好。我吗？对，你做得很棒。
Thank you. No, you're so good at it. You're always like, you just prioritise your friends. You do things that make you happy. Like, she works 9 to 5 and she still has time to volunteer. Like, I haven't volunteered for about six years. Well, it's what you value, right? I don't value work.
谢谢。不，你在这方面太厉害了。你总是，你只是把朋友放在首位。你做那些让你高兴的事。比如，她朝九晚五上班，却依然有时间做志愿者。比如，我已经大约六年没做过志愿者了。好吧，这取决于你重视什么，对吧？我不重视工作。
So I think I do put a lot of time and energy into doing things. Like on almost every day that I work, because I work four days at the moment, on two of those four days, so 50% I have a set activity that I know I will be doing every week. And then the other 50% of that time, I usually feel with spending time with friends. So I go to poll on Tuesday night, which I love. So that's like my first day back at work, absolutely heinous, gross. But I get to go to poll on the evening. And that's something I really like.
所以我想我确实花了很多时间和精力去做各种事情。比如在我工作的几乎每一天——目前我一周工作四天——在这四天中的两天，也就是50%的时间里，我都有一个固定活动，我知道自己每周都会去做。然后另外50%的时间，我通常用来和朋友们在一起。所以我周二晚上去跳钢管舞，我很喜欢。所以那是我回到工作岗位的头一天，绝对极其痛苦、糟糕。但我晚上可以去跳钢管舞。那是我非常喜欢的事情。
I tried to get her into spin classes, but we tried once. We tried spin on Wednesday. I cycle, so why would I spin when I cycle? But still loved it, still loved it, of course. Yeah, and then on Thursday I played netball, and it's like social netball, which is amazing. And I never picture myself playing netball either. But it's really good because I get to spend time with a whole bunch of people that I really like, and they're super lovely. And then on Friday, I usually do something really fun with my friends.
我试图让她去上动感单车课，但我们尝试过一次。我们在周三试过动感单车。我平时骑自行车，既然我骑自行车，为什么还要去踩动感单车呢？但还是很喜欢，依然很喜欢，当然。对，然后周四我打无板篮球，那是那种社交性质的无板篮球，太棒了。我以前从没想过自己会打无板篮球。但这真的很好，因为我可以和一大群我非常喜欢的人在一起，他们超级可爱。然后周五，我通常会和朋友们一起做一些非常有趣的事。
Yeah, normally we get drunk. Or I go out for drinks. They're actually, that's an interesting. topic, people drinking to forget the fact that they have to work five days a week, because I think that is a big thing to talk about. That's a big trend, especially in Canberra where a lot of people have disposable incomes and no children. And a job that means that they have both days on the weekend off.
对，通常我们会喝醉。或者我出去喝一杯。这其实是一个有趣的话题，人们喝酒是为了忘掉他们不得不一周工作五天的事实，因为我认为这是一个很值得探讨的大趋势。这是一个很大的潮流，特别是在堪培拉，很多人有可支配收入，又没有孩子。而且这份工作意味着他们周末两天都可以休息。
Yeah. So it's also a lot of young people. Like, I feel like most of the people who are listening, but like it's a lot of people who are like under the age of 30, moved it for the APS, and have just come in to heaps of money off and moved out of home. And it is a huge thing. Also, the big thing is if you're young, like, this is meant to be your time to really figure yourself out. If you're working all the time, when you do have time off, there's this huge compulsion
对。所以年轻人也很多。就像，我觉得大多数在听节目的听众也是这样，有很多30岁以下的人，为了澳大利亚公共服务署（APS）搬到这里，刚拿到一大笔钱，然后搬出了家。这确实是一件大事。还有，很重要的一点是，如果你还年轻，这就是你真正摸索自己的时期。如果你一直在工作，当你终于有空闲时间时，就会有一种强烈的冲动
to be like, I need to have fun. I need to be fun. I need to, like, do things, make memories. And often that's like, well, I need to be drunk. Or like, what's the Canberra? In Canberra, there's not much to do. If you're okay, we're not really outdoorsy people. Like we have a lot of friends who like, you ride your bike,
觉得：我需要玩得开心。我需要变得有趣。我需要，比如，做点事情，创造回忆。通常那意味着，好吧，我需要喝醉。或者说，堪培拉有什么？在堪培拉，其实没多少可玩的。如果你——好吧，我们其实不是那种喜欢户外活动的人。比如我们有很多朋友喜欢——你骑自行车，
but like we have friends who are like, go to the snow. Ultra marathon runners. Kate. Shout to Kay. Yeah. Tenaia, Lucy, they always go skiing. Like they always cycle, Meg. Yeah.
但我们也有那种会去雪山的朋友。超级马拉松跑者。凯特。向凯伊致敬。对，蒂娜娅、露西，他们总是去滑雪。比如他们总是骑自行车，梅格。对。
I think there's a lot of people who do the weekend activities that require traveling and then your whole weekend is spent camping. I wish I could be that person. I think we should work on it maybe. Um. Hey, we're going to break. with this weekend. We are. We're going to brave with us. That's making the most year weekend. Yeah, but this is the thing. We need, we got off. Well, actually, quickly. Yeah, please. Sorry,
我觉得有很多人在周末会进行需要旅行的活动，然后你的整个周末就都在露营中度过了。我真希望自己能成为那样的人。我想我们也许应该为此努力。呃。嘿，我们这个周末要休息。我们是的。我们要休息。这就是充分利用周末。对，但问题就在这里。我们需要，我们偏离了……其实，等等，快说。对，请说，抱歉，
we often get off track in our conversations in case you haven't noticed. That's the thing, right? And if you have three days a weekend, three days on your weekend, you can have a day going on a little trip. Yeah. And your other days, you don't only then have one day to get your whole life together and then go back to work on one day. You have two days to get your life back together and go back to work on a day. Or you could take a night time. You could go for a night. I mean, you could do that, I guess, if you've only got two days a week. Yeah. Two days a week off. Just basically what we're saying is so much more opportunity. Just to do more things. Yeah. And like Aaron was saying, and like we kind of went off this point a little bit, but I do really want to talk about it because I think you
我们的谈话经常偏离主题，以防你还没注意到。事情就是这样，对吧？如果你有三天周末，周末有三天时间，你可以有一天去进行一次小旅行。对。而你剩下的日子里，不仅只有一天时间来把你的整个生活收拾好，然后就在仅剩的一天后回去上班。你有两天时间来重新收拾好生活，然后挑一天回去上班。或者你可以抽出一个晚上。你可以去过夜。我的意思是，如果你一周只有两天假的话，你大概也可以那样做。对。一周只有两天假。基本上我们的意思是，有更多的机会去做更多的事情。对。就像艾伦刚才说的，而且我们刚刚有点偏离了这个重点，但我真的很想谈谈它，因为我觉得你
raise a really good point. When everyone's young, everyone's been forced into these lives that they don't necessarily love. You've kind of cut short your young years. Oh my goodness. Premature. Like, I'm 21. I've become like a 50 year old. I've, I'm sitting here on my, on my couch with my cat. Yeah. Am I? Drinking tea? Are I 50?
提出了一个非常好的观点。当每个人都还年轻的时候，每个人都被迫过上了他们其实并不真正热爱的主流生活。你某种程度上缩短了你的青春年华。哦天哪。太早熟了。比如，我21岁。我已经变得像个50岁的人了。我，我正坐在我的，我的沙发上陪着我的猫。对。我是吗？在喝茶？我才50岁吗？
No. What happened to my like 20s? But this is the thing because you always have that like what happened to my 20s, what happened to my young years? Where were they? What did I do? Yeah. And it was gone and now I've sitting in an office. Yeah.
不。我的20几岁怎么了？但这就是问题所在，因为你总会有那种感觉：我的20几岁怎么了，我的青春年华去哪了？它们在哪里？我都干了些什么？对。然后它就没了，现在我坐在办公室里。对。
I know. Now you sit in an office and I think that is a thing that really like, because this is the time to be young and like we're talking about psychology here, our brains don't really want to be pushed in. We're still developing. So our brains are seeking new stimulation, new memories, new experiences. So you often see like there's nothing to do on the weekend. A lot of people have disposable income. Go out and get drunk. Go out and drink and forget that, you know, you have to go to work in the day. Yeah. And then, you know, it's awful because then you get really hung over and then your whole Sunday's gone anyhow. So now you only have a one day weekend. Yeah. It sucks. You know, there is actually
我知道。现在你坐在办公室里，我觉得这是一件让人真正——因为这是保持年轻的时期，我们现在在探讨心理学，我们的大脑其实并不想被压抑。我们还在发育中。所以我们的大脑一直在寻求新的刺激、新的回忆、新的体验。所以你经常会看到，好像周末没什么事可做。很多人都有可支配收入。那就出去喝醉。出去喝酒，把白天必须去上班的事忘掉。对。然后，你知道的，这太糟糕了，因为接下来你会宿醉得很厉害，然后你的整个星期天就这样泡汤了。所以现在你只有一个一天的周末了。对。这太烂了。你知道，其实
there is actually a formula to making your days good. What is it? I've told you about this before, right? No, you have never told me about this. No. Okay, so again, my beautiful psychologist, shout out. She said that when I started having my Mondays off, she said, okay, that's great. Don't spend all day on the couch resting because whilst rest is great, you need to do something that makes you feel fulfilled.
其实有一个让你的日子过得美好的公式。是什么？我以前跟你说过这个吗？没有，你从来没跟我说过这个。没有。好吧，那么再次说明，我那美丽的心理学家——向她致敬。她说，当我开始在周一休假时，她说，好的，这很好。不要整天躺在沙发上休息，因为虽然休息很好，但你需要做一些能让你感到内心充实的事情。
And so she said that you need to do something on that day that brings you joy. Yeah. So something that you really like. So that could be like spending time with friends or cooking something nice. I often like do a little bit of planting, like a new little plant, plants and seedlings. Painting. Painting. Reading.
所以她说，你需要在那天做一些能给你带来快乐的事情。对。也就是你真正喜欢的事情。所以那可以是和朋友共度时光，或者做点好吃的。我经常喜欢种种植物，比如弄一点新植物、植物和树苗。画画。画画。阅读。
Reading. Something that's practical. So prepping dinner for next week. Laundry. I often try to clean every Monday. So the house is nice and clean for the. the week ahead. You need to do something that's cognitive.
阅读。做一些实用的事。比如为下周准备晚餐。洗衣服。我通常试着在每周一打扫卫生，这样接下来的这一周家里就能保持干净整洁。你需要做一些需要动脑的事。
So itaches the scratch in your brain. So an easy one is watching a documentary. But Scrabble. Scrabble. Crosswords. Crosswords. Scrabble. I guess.
这样能抓挠到你大脑的痒处。最简单的就是看纪录片。或者玩拼字游戏。拼字游戏。填字游戏。填字游戏。拼字游戏。我猜吧。
I haven't thought of that one. Words. Or like researching a topic that you're really into or like a new qualification that you want podcast about something scientific or that's kind of my. realm of interest is like science and the climate and stuff like that or like doing a bit of reading you read the i read heaps you read so much but you read really intellectual stuff i don't think so i think i just read like really weird novels that are like kind of whack like you were talking about reading that article oh yeah so my friend got like a new yorker subscription and um like when he's finished
我还没想过那个。文字。或者研究一个你真正感兴趣的话题，比如你想了解的某个新资格证书，或者听一个关于科学之类播客。这基本上是我的兴趣领域，比如科学、气候之类的话题，或者做点阅读。你阅读量很大，你读了超级多书，但你读的都是非常深刻的知识类内容吧。我不这么觉得，我觉得我只是读一些非常古怪的小说，有点离谱那种。就像你之前说在读的那篇文章。哦对，我朋友订了一份《纽约客》，然后等他看完了，
with them he like gives them to me and i read this really insanely good article about the rise of ovarian cancer and like rural alabama and like the intersection between that and like medicaid and how like yeah this is a real detour but it's a really good article so that's something that's cognitive right yeah and it was actually was really fulfilling because i read it right before bed and i felt like i'd done something that challenged my brain rather than just pressing your button on an excel spreadsheet um and then you've got to do something that's physical so exercise so go for a walk um i love going for a walk up a hill where i live at the moment and if you time it right you can see a little sunset which is gorgeous
就会送给我。我读了一篇好得离谱的文章，讲的是阿拉巴马州农村地区卵巢癌的发病情况，以及这与医疗补助（Medicaid）之间的交织，还有诸如此类的事情。是的，这扯得有点远，但真的是篇好文章。所以这也是一种需要动脑的事，对吧？是的，而且实际上非常有成就感，因为我是在睡前读的，我觉得自己做了点挑战大脑的事，而不是只是在电子表格上按按按钮。然后，你还得做一些体力活动，比如锻炼，去散步。我很喜欢在我目前住的地方爬爬山，如果时间算得准，还能看到美丽的日落。
that's like a combination of joy combination of joy all the others all the others I come up of joy so something that brings you joy something that is practical yeah something that's cognitive
那是快乐的结合，所有这些加起来就是快乐。所以，做一件能带给你快乐的事，做一件实用的事，做一件需要动脑的事，
and something that's physical there you go there's the equation that's the equation so if you do all of those things in your day then you'll feel better you'll feel better but I don't want to say you'll be happy because happiness is a construct
再做一件体力活动。好了，这就是公式！这就是公式！所以如果你在一天里把这些事情都做了，你就会感觉更好。你会感觉更好，但我不想说你会因此感到幸福，因为幸福只是一个建构出来的概念。
but it is that really helps me. And that makes me feel like I've... Because productivity sometimes I think can... There's a very narrow field of what productivity actually is. And I think sometimes there's a big push to be productive
但这些确实对我有很大帮助。这让我觉得……因为有时候我觉得“高产”这个词……人们对什么是高产有着非常狭隘的定义。我觉得有时候社会有一股巨大的推动力去逼你变得高产，
and what does productivity look like and the rise of the that girl... Oh yeah. ...trend on Instagram. Which we can talk about ours so we won't go into it. We'll do it on our other episodes. Yeah. But that's also tied to like professional success.
而高产究竟是什么样的呢？比如Instagram上“那个女孩（that girl）”风潮的兴起。哦对。这种趋势。我们改天可以专门聊聊这个，所以现在就不展开了。我们会在其他节目里讨论。对。但这也和职业上的成功挂钩，
and like having everything put together and like a big part of that is like having the job or like working towards the job and I think what we're really talking about here is like if we took the job out of the equation or the nine to five job would everything really fall apart or would everyone get a little bit happier? Like universal basic income.
比如把一切都打理得井井有条，而这其中很大一部分就是拥有一份工作，或者朝着拥有工作的目标努力。我觉得我们在这里真正讨论的是，如果我们把“工作”或朝九晚五的职业从这个等式中剔除，一切真的会崩塌吗？还是说每个人都会稍微快乐一点？就像全民基本收入（UBI）那样。
Just look at the studies done with universal basic income and how those that want to work work people who find joy in working work and people who don't get to pursue what they actually love. And I feel like everyone falls into place of doing things that, like, you know, that they would enjoy. Like, and that would actually, they'd be good at, they'd be specialized at. You would have more productivity and efficiency, I think, because you wouldn't have a bunch of people who feel compelled to work, but not motivated to work. Which is a huge thing I'm sure you've seen.
看看关于全民基本收入的研究，那些想工作的人还是会工作，在工作中找到乐趣的人会去工作，而那些没有找到乐趣的人则可以去追求他们真正热爱的事物。我觉得每个人都会各司其职，去做那些他们真正喜欢、擅长并且精通的事情。我认为你反而会获得更高的生产力和效率，因为你不会看到一大群被迫去工作、却毫无工作动力的人。这绝对是一个巨大的现象，我相信你也见过。
Like, so many people who are like, oh, I've got to go to work. And when they get to work, do you really think they're going to be there like, yeah, I'm at work. Like, let me put in everything I've got. let me really commit to this. No, they're not going to flip and do that, especially when you're in your 20s or in your 30s or when you're young and you have so much other shit that you want to do. And I just think like, yeah,
比如，有那么多人总是说：“哦，我得去上班了。”当他们到了公司，你真的觉得他们会全情投入地说：“太棒了，我在上班，让我奉献出我的一切，让我真正致力于此”吗？不，他们才不会发神经似地这么做，尤其是当你正值二十多岁或三十多岁，或者当你还年轻，还有一堆其他想做的事情的时候。我只是觉得，对吧，
I just don't think that it necessarily works. And I think with what you were saying about that equation, you've got these four things you need to prioritize. Do you find it easier to do it on days when you're not working or days when you are? Oh, I don't think about it on days I work because I simply do not have time. There we go. Because by the time, I have woken up
我就是觉得这不一定行得通。关于你刚才提到的那个公式，有这四件事需要你去优先处理。你觉得在不上班的日子里更容易做到，还是在上班的日子里更容易？哦，我在上班的日子里根本不会去想这些，因为我根本没时间。就是这样！因为等我……醒来，
Yeah Got myself to work Been at work Come home I've got what Three or four hours left in the day Yeah And most of that is spent
对，赶去上班，在公司上班，回到家，我一天还剩什么？三四个小时？对，而且大部分时间都花在……
Eating dinner Or having to cook dinner So you're home by five You want to be in bed by 10 Yeah Yeah you want to be in bed by 10 So you don't feel like Absolute crap
吃晚饭，或者不得不做晚饭。所以你五点钟到家，十点钟就想上床睡觉了。对，对，你十点钟就想上床睡觉，这样第二天早上才不会觉得自己简直像坨狗屎。你需要洗澡，需要收拾屋子，做任何你需要在家做的事情。照顾好自己，吃东西。所以到了最后，作为一个稍微有点内向的人，
The next morning You've got a shower You've got to tidy up Do whatever you need to do in your house Yeah Take care of yourself eat So at the end of the day often as somebody who is a little bit introverted,
我往往只是坐着看电视，因为我觉得自己实在没有脑力去应付任何稍微有点挑战性的事情了。或者你会去做一些有益的事，比如去打无板篮球（netball），这就兼顾了你的体力活动和快乐。虽然不是很实用，但是，对吧，既有体力运动又充满快乐，这两件事真的很棒，也多少需要动脑，
I often just sit and watch television because I'm like, I do not have the mental capacity to do anything else that is slightly challenging. Or you go and do something that is good, like you go to netball, there's your physical thing, and there's your joy thing, not really practical, but yeah, like physical and joyful, there's two things that are really nice, somewhat cognitive,
但这也意味着你照顾自己的时间变少了。完全是这样。所以这就是整个问题的症结所在：当你的八天里有八个小时没了，前两三个小时又全花在手忙脚乱地准备和通勤上……好吧，其实我在床上躺了一个小时，因为我真的不想去上班。
but it's also like, but then you have less time to take care of yourself. Completely. So it's this whole thing, if it's like, when eight hours of your day are gone and the first three hours, two hours are spent just fucking getting ready and going to work well, I lie in bed for an hour because I literally don't want to go to work.
哦，太糟糕了。我总是把闹钟定在七点十分，但我七点四十才起。对，因为我喜欢醒来后赖一会儿床。因为如果我七点四十才醒，接下来的一天肯定不会太顺利。
Oh, terrible. I always set my alarm at 10 past seven, but I get up at 7.40. Yeah. Because I like to wake up and then be like, oh, I get a snooze a little bit. Because if I wake up at 7.40, I'm going to be like, it's just not going to go well.
对，而且我把起床的时间压缩得越来越极限。比如今天我七点五十才醒，当时我就想：完蛋。对，其实我希望有四十分钟的时间准备出门。曾经有一段时间，我把出门准备时间完美压缩到了十五分钟，那时我对上班感到太沮丧了，根本起不来床。这可不是什么好状态，不过我现在已经走出来了。
Yeah, and I've really been cutting it thinner and thinner. Like, today I work up at 750 and I was like, shit. Yeah. I want 40 minutes to get out the door. I've actually, I managed to perfect it down to 15 minutes getting out of the door at one stage when I just was so sad about going to work. I couldn't get out of bed. Which is not a, that's not a good space to be in and I'm not there anymore.
当我刚开始做朝九晚五的工作时？而且确实有几次，我真的……我早上根本起不来床，结果睡过头了。然后我十一点醒来，不得不打电话给公司跟他们沟通，说：“嘿，发生了一些状况，我目前的心理健康状况不太好。”幸运的是，他们都非常理解。你觉得这种状态有多少是和工作绑定的？你觉得这只是生活平衡问题，还是有其他原因？我觉得这绝对、百分之百和工作有关。
When I first started working my 9 to 5 job? And there have been occasions as well that I have literally had to, like, I've not been able to get out of bed in the morning and I've slept in. And then I've woken up at 11 and I've had to call work and have a chat to them and be like, hey, this is going on. My mental health is not great at the moment. And luckily they've been really understanding. How much of that do you think was tied to work? Do you think it was just like a balance or other things? I think it really, it really was tied to work.
And it was tied to the fact that I had no time for myself and I was just so exhausted. And my mind was just not able to cope at all. And I think as well, like if you have a mental illness, like I find it really important to have time. to prioritize just looking after myself. Because sometimes looking after yourself is quite difficult. And sometimes it does like take time to do things that other people could do quite quickly. Yeah. You know?
这其实和我当时没有留出时间给自己、整个人筋疲力尽有关。我的大脑根本无法应付这一切。我觉得，如果你患有心理疾病，留出时间来优先照顾自己真的非常重要。因为有时候照顾好自己相当不容易，而且做那些其他人可能觉得很快就能完成的事，有时确实需要花时间。对吧？你知道的吗？
So part of that is like if I have more time on the weekend, it is easier to do stuff like that. Yeah. No, that's a really big thing. And I'm glad that you kind of, um, recognize that and kind of took control and were like, yeah, this needs to change. But it's, you know, and you were really lucky that you, they were. somewhat yeah no I was really lucky flexible around that somewhat flexible yeah
所以其中一部分原因就是，如果我在周末有更多时间，做那样的事情就会更容易。对，没错，这是一个很大的改变。我很高兴你能够，嗯，意识到这一点，并且掌控了局面，觉得“对，这种情况必须改变”。不过，你知道的，你真的很幸运，他们对这方面……怎么说呢，还算挺灵活的。多少有点灵活，对吧。
but do you think if you weren't working your nine to five what do you think you would be doing or is that too much of a scary question no um sorry I'm I'm taking a moment to think yeah I um I had a concept of one stage of really wanting to be able to do woofing which is like working on an organic farm
但你觉得，如果你没有在做朝九晚五的工作，你觉得你会做什么？还是说这个问题太吓人了？不，嗯，抱歉，我正在花点时间思考。嗯，我曾经有个想法，在某个阶段特别想去参加WWOOFing，也就是在有机农场打工。
what's it all woofing W-O-O-F F? Maybe just one F. And so basically you work on an organic farm for free in exchange for like shelter and food. Wow. This is a real socialist episode. Universal basic income, free accommodation. Well, because I was, I think I really enjoy doing things where they're super practical. And whilst I did not grow up in a farm by any shape or form, I love plants. which you know.
那到底是什么？WWOOFing，是W-O-O-F-F吗？也许只有一个F。基本上就是你在有机农场免费干活，以换取住所和食物。哇，这一期可真是一场社会主义节目啊。全民基本收入，免费住宿。嗯，因为我觉得，我真的很喜欢做那些非常实用、接地气的事情。虽然我根本不是在农场长大的，但我很喜欢植物，你们也知道。
Yes, she does. I own a lot of house plans. I'm staring at them all right now. It's about 15. They are very hard to miss. They are in your face. Well, there's 15 on that one table alone. I know.
是的，她确实喜欢。我有很多室内植物。我现在正盯着它们呢。大概有15盆吧。非常显眼，就在你眼前。嗯，光是那张桌子上就有15盆。我知道。
And then you just look around and there's even more. But yeah, I just love the concept of like maybe live in a commune. Yeah. Oh, gosh. That's a terrible thing to say. No, it's not. It's not at all. But why?
然后你环顾四周，发现还有更多。不过，是的，我就是很喜欢那种也许可以住在公社里的概念。天哪，说出这种话真让人觉得不好意思。不，完全不会。一点也不。但为什么呢？
I feel like it's very like, no, basic. No, it's not. But if it's basic, we have to also examine, like, why do so many people want to do, like, how many people listening have those fantasies of dropping everything and going and living in a van or traveling the world or moving to a new country or, like, living in a commune? I think it's super stigmatized because it's the absolute other end of the spectrum from what, like, capitalist society expects of you. Yeah. And sometimes it's stigmatized. Like, you're trying to be, like, unique. Like, oh, look at you go.
我觉得这听起来很……不对，是很基本的需求。不，并不是。但如果这很基础，我们也必须审视一下，为什么会有这么多人想这样做？有多少听众也曾幻想过抛弃一切，去开着面包车生活、环游世界、搬到一个新的国家，或者住进公社？我觉得这被严重污名化了，因为它完全背离了资本主义社会对你的期望。对啊。有时候它被污名化是因为，好像你在刻意标新立异，像是在说“哦，瞧你多特立独行”。
It's like, actually, maybe you're just doing the thing that's right for you and you just. are scared that you can't do it. Well, who is meant to be living in an office? No one. Not living, sorry. Well, practically. Yeah. If you consider you're spending how much?
这就好比，其实你可能只是在做对你来说正确的事情，只是害怕自己做不到。话说回来，到底谁天生就该呆在办公室里生活？没有人。不是“生活”，抱歉。好吧，从现实角度来说。对。如果你算一下你花了多少……
Well, 35% of your waking hours at work, but that does not include, you know, the time spent getting ready for work, the commute. Like, I'm, what, like an hour commute every day? Oh, my goodness. Like, I have to leave 30 minutes earlier, and then it takes me 30 minutes to get home. It's another hour. Then you have to fucking get ready for work. then you have to depress from work
好吧，清醒时间的35%都花在了工作上，但这还不包括准备上班的时间、通勤时间。比如我，每天通勤要花多久？哦天哪！我必须提前30分钟出门，然后花30分钟回家，这就又是一个小时。接着你还得他妈的准备去上班，然后下班后还得缓解工作带来的沮丧。
and then you have to have a shower and then if you want to go to the gym like there's just all these things that become so much more limited whereas if you worked in a commune you really have a lot more time just to actually exist and know yourself and I think that's so important
然后你还得洗个澡，如果你想去健身的话——所有这些事情都会受到很大的限制。相比之下，如果你在公社工作，你确实会有多得多的时间来真正地存在、去认识自己，我觉得这太重要了。
and what working in an office does not do is allow you space or time to be an individual because that's the last thing that capitalism will want yeah can you imagine oh the world would fall apart
办公室工作绝对无法做到的一点，就是给你作为个体的空间或时间，因为这正是资本主义最不希望看到的。对啊，你能想象吗？那这个世界就要土崩瓦解了。
If people actually realize that, and again, if this is your goal in life, I'm not dissing it. But moving up in a workplace, what is it, like, what is it going to serve you? What are you going to get from that? Yeah. Apart from like a weird narcissistic sense of power. And money. And money, obviously. Yeah.
如果人们真的意识到了这一点——再次说明，如果这是你的人生目标，我并不是在贬低它——但在职场上往上爬，到底有什么意义？这能为你带来什么？你能从中得到什么？除了那种诡异的自恋式的权力感。还有钱。还有钱，当然了。对。
I thought this as well, because I think when I was in high school, I was really like, all I want to do is make heaps of money and be super successful and everyone admire me. But why did you want to do that? Because I didn't have anything else that I thought would bring me meaning. Wow. So that's the thing, because I was like, this is what I've been taught will bring me meaning. This is what I imagine. People admire people who are rich. People admire people who are successful.
我也曾经这么想过，因为我觉得当我还在读高中时，满脑子想的就是“我只想赚大钱，变得超级成功，让所有人都崇拜我”。但你为什么想那样做呢？因为我想不出还有什么别的东西能给我带来意义。哇。所以这就是关键所在，因为我觉得这就是我被教导能带来意义的东西。这就是我所想象的。人们崇拜有钱人。人们崇拜成功的人。
And I'm so dependent on people admiring me. And then I got to uni and about my second, third year, I was like really restructured that whole ideal. And I just had this moment where I was just like, that is actually not going to work for me. It's not going to work for me because I'm a bit of a hypocrite because I do work for nine to five now. Don't I? But is your one life goal to become the CEO? Hell no. Exactly.
而我是那么依赖别人的崇拜。等我上了大学，大概在大二大三的时候，我彻底重塑了这种理想。我当时突然有了一种顿悟，觉得那种方式对我来说根本行不通。它对我行不通，因为我现在其实也在做着朝九晚五的工作，我成了一个伪君子，对吧？但你的人生终极目标是当上首席执行官吗？绝不。完全正确。
Hell no. You're not a hypocrite. You just exist within a capitalist society. But also I'm working because I know that I need money to go off and do the things that I want to do. And I think I've also been able to do other stuff alongside it. Like I do this podcast, like have heaps of time for other things in my life. But yeah, I think that that was a huge thing that I had on my mind. Like, this is what I need for my life.
绝不。你不是伪君子，你只是生活在一个资本主义社会里。但同时我工作是因为我知道我需要钱去追求和做我想做的事情。而且我觉得我也能同时兼顾其他事情。比如我做这个播客，生活中还有大把时间做别的事。不过，是的，我觉得这曾是我脑海中的一件大事。就像是，这就是我生活所需要的。
Like, this is what I want. And then I had to completely rethink it. And I used to always be like, oh, I don't imagine people who are like, you're just going to be a bum all day. I was very conservative. I'm not now. Obviously, I was discussed in the last episode. Yeah, yeah.
这就是我想要的。然后我不得不彻底重新思考。我以前总是觉得，“哦，我可不希望别人觉得我整天就是个游手好闲的废人”。我以前非常保守。现在当然不是了，上一期节目里显然也讨论过了。对，对。
Done a full 180. But I really think it's like restructuring your priorities. And I think a lot of people hit that point where they have that conundrum. And why do you think people have a mid-like? crisis yeah exactly that's i mean like because quarter life crisis is a quarter life crisis because you realize that like what you're doing what what what's it actually and i think actually quickly um COVID has had a huge huge like generated huge societal shift into wow okay life's actually quite short yeah life is really uncertain we don't know what's going on yeah so you better
来了个180度大转弯。但我真的觉得这就像是重塑你的优先事项。而且我觉得很多人都会到达那个节点，经历那种困惑。你觉得为什么人们会有类似“中年”危机？对，没错。我是说，因为“四分之一人生危机”之所以被称为四分之一人生危机，是因为你意识到你正在做的事情，到底有什么实际意义？而且我觉得，说真的，新冠疫情极大地推动了全社会的转变，让人意识到：哇，原来生命其实挺短暂的。对，生命真的很不确定，我们根本不知道会发生什么。所以你最好
do something that you actually enjoy. Yeah, and family, spend time with family. And I actually think that as well. And also just like how many workplaces, you know, how much we realize that actually you could take time off? Oh. Like you could work from home. Quickly.
去做一些你真正喜欢的事情。还有家人，花时间陪家人。我其实也这么觉得。还有就是很多职场，你知道的，我们意识到其实你是可以请假休息的！哦。比如你可以居家办公。等等。
You could be flexible. Half pay. What was that? I don't know whether that's available to you, but it's a bit of a thing in the APS. If you take leave, take leave with half pay. if you can afford it because basically for that day of leave or days of leave you will get half your pay but that means you get twice as much leave. Oh if you can afford it.
你可以选择半薪假。刚才说什么来着？我不知道这是否适合你，但在澳大利亚公共服务署（APS）里这挺常见的。如果你请假，可以选择休半薪假，如果你经济上负担得起的话。因为基本上，对于你请的那一天或几天假，你只拿一半的薪水，但这意味着你的假期能翻倍。哦，如果你负担得起的话。
If you can afford it. Concept. I didn't know that was something people could do until like eight months into working in this job. I want to do that. I don't get leave. You don't get leave. Are you a contractor? Well yeah, I just get, I'm not on a permanent contract.
如果你负担得起的话。这概念。我直到在这份工作里干了大概八个月才知道原来人们可以这样做。我也想这么休假。我没有带薪假。你没有带薪假？你是合同工吗？对啊，我只是……我签的不是长期合同。
Yeah. So I'm technically casual but I work. Well, but I don't know. but I'm on a semi-permanent basis working nine to five. Oh my goodness. But I think it's just because I started out there as someone who was like just there as like a support person like as a researcher and then I got like promoted. That's how they get you. No.
是的。所以我技术上是临时工，但我在工作。嗯，不过我不知道。但我是一份半永久性质的工作，朝九晚五。哦，天哪。但我认为这只是因为我刚开始在那里时是一个支持人员，比如作为一个研究人员，然后我得到了晋升。他们就是这样套牢你的。不是的。
I love my workplace but like it's not the workplace that I don't like. It's the concept of the work life. Yes. That's a really big thing to distinguish. Well, I truly and I have had a serious existential breakdown. about this before now in front of my mom and my brother where I literally lay on the kitchen floor and I cried because I was like, why can I not simply receive money for existing? Yeah.
我喜欢我的工作场所，但像这样，我讨厌的不是工作场所。而是工作生活的概念。是的。这是一个非常重要需要区分的概念。嗯，我真的，我以前经历过一次严重的生存危机，现在就在我妈妈和哥哥面前，我真的躺在厨房的地板上哭泣，因为我觉得，为什么我不能仅仅因为存在就能拿到钱？是的。
Why do I need money? Why do I need money and why do I have to work to a gidist? And I can hear the economic bros shouting at me as I say this. Shut up Brad and that's your name. Oh gosh. Oh. Something lame like that. Oh.
为什么我需要钱？为什么我需要钱，为什么我必须为了一个既定的系统去工作？当我这么说的时候，我可以听到那些经济学男高谈阔论的声音。闭嘴吧，布拉德，这就是你的名字。噢天哪。噢。类似于这种很逊的名字。噢。
But why, like, why? Yeah. Why do humans, like, we've created, obviously, this you should do. Yeah. But why, why do, like, why don't we choose a better one? Nothing about me existing actually requires dollar, dollar bills. Yeah. Nothing.
但是为什么，就像，为什么？是的。为什么人类，就像，我们显然创造了，这个你应该去做的。是的。但是为什么，为什么，就像，为什么我们不选择一个更好的？我实际存在的事情并没有什么需要美刀，美刀纸币。是的。什么都没有。
Right? Nothing. It obviously facilitates things like healthcare and someone where to live. But then again, why does that require dollar, dollar bills? Why does that require dollar dollar bills? Yeah, we got to go back to them. It wouldn't. Well, once upon a time, it wouldn't have. I mean bartering.
对吧？什么都没有。它显然促进了诸如医疗保健和居住地之类的事情。但话说回来，为什么这需要美刀纸币？为什么这需要美刀纸币？是的，我们得回到它们。它本不会。好吧，曾几何时，它本不会。我是说物物交换。
But you also would have died at 35. But I also would have died. Oh, I would have died very early on. I got sick as a very young child. I would have been killed off early. Oh. We do not condone infanticide on the sky. No, no, no, no.
但你也会在35岁时死掉。但我也会死。哦，我会很早就死掉。我还是个幼儿的时候就生病了。我很早就被淘汰了。哦。我们不赞成在这个节目中进行杀婴行为。不，不，不，不。
I'm sorry. No, I'm kidding. I'm teasing. No, but you're right. Like, why does everything require money? And that's what I think we were really getting out. What's the pressure? The pressure is money.
我很抱歉。不，我在开玩笑。我在逗你玩。不，但你是对的。就像，为什么每件事都需要钱？这就是我认为我们真正想表达的。压力是什么？压力就是钱。
Yeah. The pressure is two things, actually, like kind of what I was saying, the pressure to be need to be conformity. and to be doing what you think is going to give you meaning and work is what is given so many generations of people meaning because that was really a necessity and also money and money allows you to do other things
是的。实际上压力有两件事，有点像我刚才说的，需要顺从的压力，以及去做你认为会给你带来意义的事情的压力，而工作给那么多代人带来了意义，因为那确实是必需品，还有钱，钱允许你做其他事情
but it's like that equation it's like another equation where it's like at what point do you not even have the time to spend the money that you are earning because you wanted to spend money on things that you like and at what point are you just accumulating wealth and for who? Yeah, where's that going to go when you're dead? Where's that going to go when you're dead?
但这就好像那个方程式，就像另一个方程式，就像在哪个时间点上，你甚至没有时间去花你正在赚的钱，因为你想把钱花在你喜欢的事情上，而在哪个时间点上，你只是在积累财富，为了谁？是的，当你死后这会去哪？当你死后这会去哪？
And if we throw into this, the good old little climate crisis lurking in the background if we only have like how much amount of time that we have left which probably not a lot before things really hit the fan
如果我们把这个也算进去，背景中潜伏着那个美好的小气候危机，如果我们只有，比如说，我们还剩下多少时间，在事情真正搞砸之前，可能不会有太多时间
hit the fan am I going to spend 20 of the best years that we have left on this planet as human beings before we go extinct sitting in an office staring at a computer screen it's like an episode of black mirror It is like, we're living in an episode of Black Mirror.
搞砸，难道我要把作为人类在这个星球上剩下的最好的时光中的20%——在我们灭绝之前——花在坐在办公室里盯着电脑屏幕上吗？这就像一集《黑镜》。确实如此，我们正生活在《黑镜》的一集中。
We really are. But, and seriously, I'm like, so, I mean, if this is a motivation to anybody, quit your job. Are you going to quit your job? Look, I need to figure out what I want to do that is not working 9 to 5, and then I will be seriously considering. And I'm locked in. The job that I'm in right now requires a certain period of time.
我们真的在。但是，说真的，我像是在说，所以，如果这对任何人来说是一个动力，辞职吧。你打算辞职吗？听着，我需要弄清楚我想做什么，而不是朝九晚五的工作，然后我会认真考虑。而且我被锁定了。我现在的工作需要一段时间。
Yeah. to do things in. So to do things in. It's like a set contract, we'll say. So it's kind of like, but if you have the opportunity, also, if there's younger people who are like, because I remember last year I had this whole thing where I was like, I just want to get a normal job. Like I just want to work nine to five.
是的。来把事情做好。所以来把事情做好。就像一个固定的合同，我们这样说。所以有点像，但如果你有机会，另外，如果有年轻人像——因为我记得去年我有过这样的一段经历，当时我觉得我只想找一份普通的工作。就像我只想朝九晚五地工作。
And I thought that was going to make me happy. I was like, I just want to do it like that. No, no, no, no, no. Spend as much time as you can on a, centerlink. if you have that option or be just like doing other things working jobs that are you know might be different hours but like
我以为那会让我快乐。我当时想我只想那样做。不，不，不，不，不。花尽可能多的时间在领中心（Centerlink），如果你有这个选择，或者只是去做其他事情，做那些你知道可能会有不同工作时间但
are a lot more suitable for your lifestyle having a nine to five job fitting into that lifestyle doesn't actually bring meaning it doesn't make you a more mature person you don't need to rush to grow up and fit into that because you just give away so much of your freedom and even though you might have been told your whole life
更适合你的生活方式的工作。有一份朝九晚五的工作并融入那种生活方式并不能真正带来意义，它不会让你成为一个更成熟的人，你不需要急于长大并融入其中，因为你只是放弃了太多的自由，即使你可能一辈子都被告知
that that's something to aspire to and work towards sometimes it's just not It's just not. And, you know, the grass is always grown around the other side, but... Yeah, exactly. That's what... Obviously. But if you seriously, like, seriously consider what is it that brings you meaning and value?
那是值得向往和努力的事情，有时它就是不。它就是不。而且，你知道，邻家的草总是更绿，但是……是的，完全是这样。那就是……显然。但如果你认真地，认真地考虑什么才是真正给你带来意义和价值的东西？
And joy. And joy. Yeah. For probably 80% of people, it is not working in an office. No. It's not for me. No, it's not for you. Yeah.
还有快乐。还有快乐。是的。对于大概80%的人来说，那不是在办公室工作。不。对我来说不是。不，对你也不是。是的。
Oh, it is. There we go. There's 100% out of our sample of two. So. So, obviously, lessons learned. Peer-reviewed research. Yeah, literally peer-reviewed because we are peers. We need to say goodbye because we have recorded 45 minutes of this.
哦，是的。我们走吧。在我们两个人的样本中占100%。所以。所以，很显然，吸取了教训。经过同行评审的研究。是的，字面上的同行评审，因为我们是同行。我们需要说再见了，因为我们已经录了45分钟了。
But I hope, well, I hope especially that this was kind of an informative look into what it's like transitioning into 9 to 5 work when you're in your 20 years, the psychological shifts and changes that you undergo. And, yeah, what it means for your health, what it means for your sanity and your sense of self. and why it's probably not all it's cracked up to be. And, yeah, I think it was just a good discussion of the pressures that you face to fit into that mold, even if it's against your own well-being. Yeah. So thanks, Erin.
但我希望，嗯，我特别希望这能让人对20多岁时转型做朝九晚五的工作是一种什么样的体验、你所经历的心理转变和变化，有一个翔实的了解。而且，是的，这对你的健康、对你的理智和自我意识意味着什么，以及为什么它可能并不像吹嘘的那样。而且，是的，我认为这是一个很好的讨论，讨论你为了融入那个模具而面临的压力，即使这违背了你自己的福祉。所以谢谢你，埃伦。
Thanks for having me. No way. You know, I love a good chat about work. Yeah. No more work chat. No more work chats. No more work chats. Can we ban them?
谢谢你邀请我。才怪。你知道的，我喜欢好好聊聊工作。是的。再也不聊工作了。再也不聊工作了。再也不聊工作了。我们能禁止它们吗？
I think we should. I think we definitely should. Anyhow, I hope you enjoyed this episode. We'll have a new episode next week. It's The Psychology of the Breakup. And, yeah, spicy, spicy. It's a juicy, juicy episode. Oh, yeah.
我想我们应该。我想我们绝对应该。不管怎样，我希望你喜欢这一集。我们下周会有一个新节目。那是《分手的心理学》。而且，是的，非常劲爆，非常劲爆。这是一个非常精彩的节目。哦，是的。
It's juicy indeed. Everyone's giving me a knowing look. But thanks for tuning in. Follow us on Instagram and Facebook and subscribe on Apple Podcasts or Spotify or wherever you get your podcast. Thanks so much. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
确实很精彩。每个人都向我投来会意的眼神。但感谢收听。在Instagram和Facebook上关注我们，并在Apple Podcasts或Spotify或你获取播客的任何地方订阅。非常感谢。收听《回顾》播客。从1979年开始，对我和说这是一个重要的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图通过我们的朋友、喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家来理解我们是如何度过难关的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吗？我对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。